الروس أون ذا ران ، انظروا فقط إلى هذه
الصور الدرامية الجديدة حرفيًا ،
هذا قريب من باكموت ، أنت
تنظر إلى ما يبدو أن
القوات الروسية كانت تتعامل مع هذه الصور على بعد حوالي
عشرة أو نحو ذلك لأنها تجري هنا
على طول تلك الغابة  المنطقة التي تتدافع نحو
الأمان تتعرض للهجوم أه في هذا
الفيديو من أعلى حيث قلت إنهم بالقرب من
مدينة باك موت الرئيسية حيث
ركز بوتين بالطبع
قوته بالكامل لأكثر من ثمانية
أشهر والآن ترى تراجعًا متسرعًا
مثل هذا ، لدينا أيضًا مقطع فيديو
لمركبات روسية مدرعة ثقيلة تنسحب من
المنطقة في الواقع ، يدعي قائد
الجيش الروسي الخاص لديك جيني باجوسيان
صراحة أن قوات بوتين
تخسر أرضًا ، ليس فقط
مقطع الفيديو الذي تقوله
وهو  تمزيق جنرالات بوتين لإلقاء
اللوم عليهم
في الخارج وفشل
خط المواجهة
ومحاولات وزارة الدفاع لتهدئة
الوضع بطريقة ما في
الفضاء الإعلامي تقود وستؤدي إلى
مأساة عالمية للأجنحة الروسية
تنهار وخط المواجهة
يفشل  أنت تسمع ذلك من
قائد جيش بوتين الخاص وليس
الجانب الأوكراني ، أعني أنه من
المذهل جدًا فهم ما يجري
هنا
أجنبي